this video is brought to you by baksu
what's up people michael here to talk
about the video game that's set the
internet ablaze elden ring debuted to
almost a million twitch views on its
first day in the wild and thanks to some
complicated gameplay and a huge world to
explore the hype seems to be here to
stay now there are plenty of reasons to
dig this game the visuals are amazing
and the open world is littered with
bizarre adventures character and
creature designs rule and of course it
continues the great from software legacy
of making games so challenging you want
to throw your controller at your tv yet
so rewarding you buy a new controller in
tv anyway but beyond all that what
explains elden ring's explosive
popularity is there something about this
game that's uniquely suited to this
historical moment we think so and think
you might agree after watching this
wisecrack edition philosophy of elden
ring and of course spoilers ahead for
some of the game and its lore
as far as we understand it but no one
seems to know what's going on so maybe
we'll come back to this once anyone
understands the whole story but before
we get into it i want to tell you about
this video's sponsor bok su boxing is a
gourmet snack and tea subscription box
that takes you on a new culinary journey
through japan every month and because
boxing partners with snack makers that
have been in business for over 100 years
you know you're getting an authentic
sampling of flavors you wouldn't
normally have access to plus every box
comes with an informative booklet that
can tell you more about where the snacks
come from and who makes them now i was
really excited about these gobo chips
they're spicy chips made from burdock
root i'm definitely going to take these
so no one else at wisecrack gets them
i'm a huge chip guy and i imagine these
would taste really good with a crisp
japanese lager or something like that
but if you have a sweet tooth there's
lots of cookies and other stuff in here
as well so you know you could share with
your friends or keep it all for yourself
for orders placed in march subscribers
will receive the exclusive sakura season
themed box it's inspired by cherry
blossom season which people in japan
celebrate by gathering for hanami or
flower viewing get-togethers cherry
blossoms are everywhere in this box of
20 to 24 treats and you got petal
embossed cookies there's delicate cherry
flavors infused in the teas and the
candies now boxu offers free shipping to
the us straight from japan and you can
get 10 percent off your first box by
visiting the link in the description and
entering code wisecrack 10. that's code
wisecrack10 at the checkout to get 10
off your first subscription box of tasty
japanese treats now back to the show
let's start with a quick recap elegant
ring takes place in a world that has
fallen apart it's rife with creepy
monsters sunken churches and dilapidated
buildings death and decay are everywhere
after the goddess marika removed the
death rune from the elden ring assassins
responded by killing several demigods on
a night of wintry fog
the rule of death was stolen marika then
fractured the powerful titular ring into
pieces each remaining demigod grabbed a
piece of the ring this caused a war that
effectively broke the world leaving
behind a shitty dirty wasteland today
shard bearers each hold a piece of the
ring and if you can simply unite them it
seems you can return the land to
prosperity to better understand your
quest it helps to look to jacques
derrida and his concept of hauntology
coined in the 1993 book specters of marx
here's the deal derrida said that the
present is marked by a temporal
disjunction in which history seems to
break and a certain narrative of the
past haunts the present like a ghost
daredevil was responding to what the
west saw as the death of communism after
the fall of the berlin wall but he
argued that marxism never died rather it
lived on as a specter continuing to
haunt western society for some that
specter is frightened a looming threat
with the potential to destroy western
capitalism for others that spectre is
mournful because they view marxism as a
ghost of lost potential a specter of a
world that could have been and the
future that could have been remains a
ghostly presence gone but never
forgotten aspects of the marxist dream
are seen in fits and starts but never
with the same momentum or clarity as in
the past like when bernie sanders ran a
presidential campaign that while
definitely not marxist was based on
dismantling certain structures of
neo-liberal capitalism in order to
facilitate greater equality we see
ontology alive and well in america in
the lingering nostalgia for the 1950s a
time supposedly defined by happy
housewives a booming economy affordable
housing and college education for all
white picket fences and leave it to
beaver seem infinitely more attractive
than what the present has to offer the
specter of the 50s thus leaves us
longing for america's glory days we see
the same mythologizing throughout elden
ring it's a world defined by its
destruction but even the most tragic
ruins you encounter seem to whisper
faint memories of past glory indeed this
was even embedded in the development
process george r.r martin was recruited
to build the world of elden ring's
glorious past then miyazaki and ko
brought that world to present day and
turned it nasty a castle with collapsed
towers evokes halcyon days of flying
banners and pageantry there's even a
secret boss fight where time rewinds and
a dragon returns to life to reassert its
power and glory remnants of an ancient
glorious past are everywhere in this
unglorious unwelcoming world and also
literal ghosts lots of ghosts haunting
us in the present so telling stories
about how great the past was is all well
and good but as with most storytelling
narratives about the past are typically
riddled with nostalgic half-truths
outright lies and everything in between
so when society creates a fabricated
version of the past what happens to the
real past that actually existed
according to darida the real less savory
version of the past sort of peeks
through society's curtains influencing
our world in subtle and not subtle ways
this is where we get the haunting part
of ontology as their real lived past
becomes the greatest ghost of all a
looming spectre haunting the present we
see this in the real version of the
1950s that continues to haunt america
racism was rampant and the redlining
that occurred continues to be realized
in unequal housing opportunities to this
day the decade also saw a major step
backwards for women in the workplace
which continues to be seen in a wage gap
that is alive and well everything from
the red scare to the genuine fear of
nuclear war to american foreign policy
decisions that wreaked havoc on south
america among other places it all gets
erased when we reminisce about america's
glory days still many of us living in an
objectively unappealing present look
back on this imagined past with
nostalgia the world of elden ring like
america has a narrativized past defined
by greatness but similarly the real past
haunts the present and suggests
something more nefarious and perhaps the
scariest ghosts in elden ring aren't the
ones lurking in creepy manners but the
world's real yet unspoken past there are
plenty of signs indicating that the
olden days were not as glorious as
everyone tells you hell if it had been
so awesome there would be no game what's
more there doesn't seem to be a
consistent vision of what the glorious
past actually was the enemies you fight
are people and creatures with opposing
motivations suggesting that the old
world wasn't so peaceful in fact it
seems to have been rife with factions
and organizations competing for power
prytile reichardt
[Music]
luna princess ronnie
willful traitors
all
it's also hinted that the legend of the
golden order supposedly supported by an
ineffable god has been given a glossy
varnish the rhythms and calculus of the
master's finger
betray a suspicion of the holism of the
golden order after all if everybody got
along so well why did things descend
into war and if the world was so perfect
why did marika decide to break it all
signs indicate that this perfect world
may have been more illusory than we're
initially led to believe how long will
it be i wonder
before the tarnished tire of a basins to
the two fingers
after all not everyone seems so big on
the whole golden order thing plenty of
characters are determined to destroy it
by burning the herd tree sure some of
those characters are horrifying like the
snake man
but some seem genuinely good like the
maiden who guides you on your quest she
even entreats you to burn down the tree
so i'd like you to undertake
a new journey
with me
to the flame of ruin
far above the clouds
upon the snowy mountaintops of the
giants
then
i can set the earth tree aflame an act
deemed the cardinal sin by others the
burning of the earth tree is the first
cardinal sin all of which suggests that
good and evil might not be so simple
here the idea of being haunted by the
past or some imagined version of it
might not be too surprising but when
writer mark fisher expanded on the idea
he identified something arguably more
disturbing when you're haunted by an
imagined past you're also haunted by
what fisher calls lost futures i.e
potential futures that could have
materialized if not for the events in
the past that closed those paths off he
cites philosopher franco berardi who
coined the phrase the slow cancellation
of the future this describes his view of
the way any hope for a happy future in
the west was eroded from the late 70s
into the 21st century as the rise of
neoliberalism attacked social welfare
lionized consumerism wreaked havoc on
the environment and so on as fisher puts
it the slow cancellation of the future
has been accompanied by a deflation of
expectations the feeling of belatedness
of living after the gold rush is as
omnipresent as it is disavowed the sense
of futurelessness in our own society can
best be realized by looking to the
comparative optimism of the 1950s back
then visions of the future were
starry-eyed just think of the jetsons
yet in our contemporary world this
vision no longer seems attainable the
vision of the future as imagined in the
50s can be considered lost yet it
continues to pervade our culture in the
form of retro-futurism i.e images and
culture technology and so on that evoke
what people in the 50s thought the
future would look like retro futurism
and culture continues to perpetuate the
jetson's vision of the future even as
that path now seems impossible such is
the power of ghost we see this too
throughout elden ring where characters
wax poetic about what could have been
had the world not been destroyed you
have nobles asking you to recapture
their lost castles daughters asking for
help finding their father even a weird
little man who just wants to live in his
cave again take the demigod radon who
was before the shattering a powerful
warrior and servant of the golden order
during the war he was infected with a
disease and driven mad in the midst of
the broken world of the lands between he
holds tournaments at a castle where
warriors can fight him for the ultimate
prize his great rune of the elden
[Music]
the
rings
is nigh
general radon
mightiest demigod of the shattering
awaits you clearly he can't let go of
his time as a warrior and ruler instead
continuing to fight trying to relive his
glory days in fact his fellow soldiers
from the war are continuing to
haphazardly fight though there's no
longer any real battlefield to fight on
clearly radon is in mourning for the
lost future where he would have
maintained his greatness so much as his
grief that he even uses his powerful
gravity magic to hold the stars in place
this keeps the world in stasis hiding
from a future where he actually has to
confront the loss and destruction of the
broken elden ring and only once you
defeat him can the stars move again so
clearly your quest within elden ring
isn't just to resurrect a lost past by
restoring the golden order it's much
bigger than that by putting the pieces
of the ring together and restoring that
past you're also reclaiming a lost
future as an extension of that glorious
pest but who benefits from this well
most of the characters urging you on are
servants or beneficiaries of the golden
order that includes both heroes and
villains who want to return to a past
they believe was taken from them but the
various endings which we'll detail more
later call the nobleness of this act
into question like many from software
games the majority of endings have you
reconstructing a version of the status
quo and instantiating a hollow version
of this lost future now underpinning the
idea of a world of lost futures is a
sense that we can no longer imagine any
kind of actually attainable future the
lost futures that haunt us simply loom
too large fisher identifies this lack of
imagination in his book capitalist
realism a term he defines as the
widespread sense that not only is
capitalism the only viable political and
economic system but also that it is now
impossible even to imagine a coherent
alternative to it though the world of
elden ring has nothing to do with
capitalism we do see a similar vibe one
of not being able to imagine an
alternative to the world in which you're
living take the demigod ranala she's
trapped in a library surrounded by her
creepy children and holding what appears
to be a squishy amber egg the game hints
that after ronald's daughter ronnie
killed herself ronald became obsessed
with this egg of rebirth
[Music]
rather than move beyond her loss into a
new future she is consumed by a desire
to recreate the daughter that she lost
she literally can't imagine an
alternative to her current situation did
not
come out say i
or will he be gravestones
to be better born a new fisher believes
that this stasis makes sense under
neoliberalism a system that is
unresponsive impersonal centerless
abstract and fragmentary in a world so
subsumed by capitalism a world that
imagines every person as primarily a
consumer everything is primarily a
product to be consumed
the prospect of change feels kind of
hollow and hopeless as he puts it
capitalism seamlessly occupies the
horizons of the thinkable fischer often
identifies this capitalist realest sense
that there is no future in our art and
culture he sees the endless postmodern
culture of remixing and remaking of
pastiche and nostalgia as evidence that
we have lost the capacity to imagine
anything that has not already been
created this dooms us to repeat the
structures of the past both in art and
in life
even the counterculture today he argues
endlessly repeat older gestures of
rebellion and contestation as if for the
first time and the concept of a society
stuck on a loop pervades elden ring far
more than you'd see in an average video
game the gameplay itself is remarkably
repetitive which is probably a good
thing given how hard it is in fact it's
basically defined by repetition
particularly with regards to death first
off you die like
a lot
no
me no but what's more when you die it's
not like in say mario where you just
reset and try again rather when you die
the runes you are carrying are lost
unless you go back and retrieve them
this forces you to return to sites of
defeat over and over again with
different approaches or better plans in
order to preserve your progress and grow
as both a player and a character each
time you know a little better what to
expect and possibly how to avoid yet
another death and that brings us to the
first not depressing part of this video
the possible emancipatory potential of
ontology and specifically of repetition
see being haunted by lost futures
doesn't doom us to a life of what ifs at
least not necessarily fisher also
believe that these ghosts can also
inspire us to see different potentials
for the world outside of our present
maybe that means imagining a world where
we don't have to rely on fossil fuels
that are slowly suffocating the planet
where you don't have to view yourself as
a sentient personal brand back in the
1960s philosopher gil de luz recognized
the potential of repetition as an active
force producing difference he saw
repetition as the power of beginning and
beginning again he was responding in
part to sigmund freud who saw repetition
as a psychological compulsion a need to
recreate a past that feels safe in its
familiarity conversely the luz inspired
by michael and kierkegaard understood
repetition as a springboard for
reinvention for conceiving of new
choices for creating spaces of
difference we see this idea of
repetition as reinvention at the core of
the game in its conclusion now most soul
games are
pretty depressing they often underscore
the futility of trying the false
illusion of choice in a universe where
most things are predetermined but not
elden ring at least not every time
notably the game offers several endings
and one everybody dies
bummer in most you restore the world
pretty close to how it used to be but
always with a wrinkle there's also one
where you burn literally everything down
in a frenzy of destruction but there's
one ending that we find really
interesting in it you restore the elden
ring but rather than handing it back to
marika and returning to the golden order
you give that power to ronnie remember
the the daughter who died by suicide but
is now back as a ghost who lives in a
doll like we said this game really is
all about haunting oh
a dogged fellow aren't we
or is it merely thy habit to talk to
dolls with this newfound power ronnie
changes the nature of the golden order
which was once a godlike force that
exerted power on and intervened in the
world under ronnie's rules the golden
order is still a system that like
gravity sets certain rules but now the
people within it have free will and can
abide by or violate its norms as they
see fit in this way a world once ruled
by predestination is now ruled by the
uncertainty that is individual choice
and choice as basically every
existentialist philosopher would tell
you is a necessary prerequisite for
freedom in this way ronnie has imagined
a different world one where visions of
the future are not dictated by myths of
the past and according to folks like
mark fisher that's what our real world
needs most people willing to conceive of
new possibilities rather than passively
accepting all the logical
inevitabilities of our present of course
if you want to reinvent the future you
have to let go of the mythologized
glorious past you were trying to restore
and accept the past as it actually was
that's the only way to stop being
haunted by it and to realize a different
future whether it's in a video game or
in the real world but what do you guys
think is elden ring a game about letting
go of the past or
are our brains just broken from trying
to understand derrida let us know what
you think in the comments a huge thanks
to all our patrons and if you haven't
checked out our patreon recently we have
a lot of very cool new stuff coming and
not in the imagined future sort of way
it's all really happening so please
check out our patreon page i think
you're gonna like what's going on set
fire to that subscribe button like
you've got a dragon head for a hand and
don't forget to ring that bell and as
always thanks for watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you